hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night my
name is markiplier and we got a Hama
which I'm assuming is gonna be used to
smash that box and a drill which is good
for padlocks now there's a moves my in
the head I can't go back so I gotta play
jump around where is he
did he disappear oh is this one of that
actually disappears after I run into him
I gotta fix everything
I have to pee I feel under way to fix it
I have to find a way to fix it I need to
find something to hit it with well okay
apparently I gotta do everything around
here what's that what's that what's this
what is this what's going on here just
some crazy glowing light standing in the
middle of a pedestal yeah that seems
normal
they're not even gonna give me torches
rainbow color someone was eating cotton
candy cuz you know cotton candy drips
when you eat it shut up shut up don't
care what you say
don't ask me how that works cuz I don't
know oh there's another way that looks
like a weight out actually so let me
just go exploring a bit I wonder if
they're like Easter eggs where I could
move forward without dealing with that
lever or that ladder but I'm very
curious I want to I want to believe that
I can fix it water Oh No
aha balderdash so this is was just way
too nothing probably just a way for the
moose man to chase me and kill me I'm
thinking I'm running oh I'm so scared
oh no I hope this is the way out oh and
then nothing death and dismemberment
okay what's in here a piece of a ladder
I need to find a way to fix that lever
get that ladder put it on the thingy and
get out of here
all sorts of colours on the ground
someone was eating a frozen slushy
that's more like it it's back there I
see something you can't hide from I'm
too smart for you
I never mind them all right
possibly not hi hey how you doing good
I'm just gonna be on my way huh okay
it's a portal a one-way port what ha ha
oh that's so cool
I've never seen a portal in this stuff
that's so cool
is cool all right let's go find out I
know there was more stuff in there he's
still there
[Music]
oh boy sisters
[Music]
Oh what do I do
I don't know what to do just stand-in
there
maybe there's something I'm supposed to
grab real quick all right
oh I hate that sounds he makes I'm just
gonna go in here in that little alchemy
and look around a bit
okay I don't see anything oh maybe I can
throw backs get him to go outside
oh well that was stupid I don't even
think that I won't you do anything put
it down
he's so ugly I could see what put some
clothes on loser playing Clank Clank Oh
banging on your walls ooh I got that in
yourself
what'd you do this nothing what are you
gonna do nothing oh you play the loser
Oh
same with you wait where'd you go you go
those what in here I saw him okay anyway
let's go take my time I wasn't looking
at that one if something oh wow I
[Laughter]
totally ruined that scare I've moved the
chair right over under stupid I'm sorry
developer who made this one I ruined
that one but that's that's pretty damn
funny
okay enough silliness there's no time
for silly I'm or oil a large oil potion
I like him big ok seriousness I was able
to get out of my cell and I think they
still didn't realize I can't find a way
out of here
it's like there's there's no doors going
outside it's like I see the light but
it's dark outside I don't get it
they've tried coming down here to look
around but I have trapped some of the
monsters that roaming the halls they
used to trap big animals so I'm using
that experience here I just need some
rope and I can make a trap but it seems
that can kill them what are they demons
of hell I'll never get back home ok so
the music is still very ominous who is
that boy ah oil for the letter let's
check all these yeah that music is still
very ominous
yeah sorry buddy it was the Iron Maiden
noise was it that was good
nope okay I'll take this little portal
oh hey Dad
something okay so I got a key hurt not
that I need that anyway but Kurt chunk
oh just like that little lack but no big
deal
alright so got the piece of ladder good
junk nothing else useful here I'm a
Lucan uh machine okay so I'm assuming
the prison keys for the door at the end
of
oh why why you're gonna splat me in the
face
ah just let me tie my hair back I'll
wait
nothing cuz I said a little bit all
right whatever
I have no time to worry about that I've
got important and these just got to do
oh come on oh okay that's okay that's
the way I went down to get the thing
that's where I got the hammer down there
that's where the monster busted out okay
I'm good I've never heard that noise
before what was that okay
okay seriously something okay I'm just
okay whatever man
[Applause]
not in the face
did I go in here there's something
behind me that I have never heard before
I swear hear that or it's numbered years
ah here we go
it's my father yeah yeah man I'm not
even into the castle apparently so this
is going to be a long long custom story
I mean the longest I ever played was
lost the lights which was like a 17 part
series which is incredible I love I love
those long ones and loss of lights was
another one that really where the the
maker just went crazy going for all the
different types of varied environments
and stuff like that which I I love I
appreciate everything these guys do to
make these incredible incredible excuse
me incredible custom sort
[Music]
alright love early I got the hammer got
the ladder oh wait the ladder was
supposed to go back there okay I'll go
back there in a bit don't worry I'll get
it I'll get it
you guys have faith in me right a little
louder
alright got the orb I'm gonna go back
for the ladder something going to pop
out hitch me be something going to happy
walking complete darkness the latter
part was where I went towards that
collapsed tunnel so right before it
collapsed
oh whoa okay oh how long has it been
there did I go down this way I got a
double check I think I have oh how are
you still alive I don't think I've been
in here chair what did you do to these
horrible these may not what horrible
things have you done I'm starting to
trust chair lesson less okay
I actually went down this way but
there's nothing here so it didn't matter
[ __ ] mannequins or sorry frakkin
mannequins
I don't like coming back here back here
is creepy okay what that's still there
punk Oh like a boss ah you saw that we
going on there
this waters too shallow for a monster I
think but you saw that something was
happening okay where's Oh aha huh can't
use it you can't use it this way I was
gonna use it come there we go
it didn't touch it right ah look at that
ah I can't get me up here though oh yeah
how am I gonna get back down
[Music]
that's the Justine monster hey buddy oh
don't tell me I just got a run passing
or something Oh better you
oh god who'd be like straight out of my
nightmares if it's just our climbing up
the ladder
cuz I've never seen that happen before
but I wouldn't be surprised at this
point look that didn't let the Doria
came in this is going away is he going
away I still hear him down there
I think I'm just gonna make this chase
scene wait until the next episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part bye bye